[Music]
hey guys look who I have here back in my
studio yeah thanks for having you back
again here Lenora Lowe's I know I'm
listen to you though Leonora is a
wellness coach and also an athlete what
are we going to talk about today Leonora
we are gonna talk about how you can find
the perfect sports bra for you which is
a really important thing and a lot of
girls take that for granted before we
get started I would like to do a really
simple poll do you wear sports bra
during training a yes every single
workout B ah ah not at all C
occasionally depending on what workout
I'm doing so we want to know your answer
right here why is it so important to
wear sports bra ladies it's important
because you are fighting against gravity
your chest is fighting it's gravity you
want to avoid any kind of back pain you
want to avoid any kind of chest pain you
also want to avoid shapping these are
just some of things that you need to be
aware of especially when it comes to
wearing the right kind of apparel when
you do any kind of training I think a
lot of us don't realize that whenever we
workout or whenever we move our breasts
are bouncing up and down in and out and
also side to side cuz remember this is
actually predominately fat so your
muscles are nice and taut but your fat
is very mobile so if say for example you
are a person with an a-cup your breast
actually moves 1 to 1.5 inches every
time we are doing exercise and for
ladies who are well-endowed the D cups
you actually move 2 to 3 inches yeah
that is a lot so just by wearing the
right type of sports bra it can reduce
the movement in half but you see not all
sports bras are the same it depends very
much on the type of activity you're
doing and also what is your body shape
your body type yeah you gotta find one
that suits you yep nowadays whenever you
walk into a sports store typically they
will label the sports bra in three kinds
low impact medium impact and also high
impact so low impact includes activities
like brisk walking yoga Pilates or your
favorite strength training boom yo
medium impact activities I like cycling
zumba skiing even though we don't do it
here in Malaysia but lots of zumba so
anything that has a bit more bounce to
your movement let's that's what you need
medium support and high-impact workout
will be my basically hit workouts
running boot can or even kickboxing so
depending on what activities you're
doing you need different types of sports
bra and Lenora you will wear different
spots prior depending on what you're
doing on that day yes I would
but since predominant mode of mine is
strength training I would usually wear
the low to medium impact it's very rare
that I actually pick a high impact
sports bra look at all the different
sports bras we have right here so we are
going to look at the construction of the
sports bra there are two types first is
compression and the second is
encapsulation so let's start with
compression which is what I have right
here so typically these types of sports
bra goes over your head and it
compresses your breasts against your
chest to really minimize the movement in
and out and this type of sports bra are
suitable for medium to low impact
activities and because there is no real
separation between the boobs it creates
sort of like a uniboob look what Leonora
is having here is actually a compression
sports bra so as you can see it creates
sort of like the face yeah yeah it
really compresses your breasts so you
sort of like a look flat yeah thanks
again again these types of sports bra
are more suitable for people with
smaller cup sizes and not great for
those with big busts it's because then
you would tend to experience a lot of
sweating and shuffling in between your
breasts and it's not gonna be very
comfortable because you can see like
even for me now already it's actually
pretty compressed in yes so obviously I
don't have any yet for
person who's more well-endowed you're
gonna find it really uncomfortable yeah
so it minimizes the movement in and out
but not really up and down and then
we've got the encapsulation bras great
for helping me pick the hot one of the
hard words so this is the encapsulation
bra it is pretty much like your everyday
bra where you actually have support for
the individual boobs if you turn the bra
round you can see inside it's like a cup
it goes inside it's like some depth to
it so this is actually great because you
will be able to minimize the movement
not a lot but it's not as compressing as
the compression bra fight Joanna you're
wearing and the encapsulation bra right
now yeah correct and it's suitable for
any type of activity depending on what
you are doing because at least then I
personally like this time because when
you are wearing any kind of outfit you
kind of still have a bit of shape yeah
correct compared to the compression
nowadays you can actually get the
combination so it's a combination of
compression which is what I have here
and also encapsulation so it goes over
your head but it has individual cups so
this sports bra is great for medium to
high impact activities it offers great
support and lots of comfort as well and
the great thing about the encapsulated
and as a compression bra if se you don't
know which brought to buy and you're on
a budget you might not just get one
which is a combination so that way you
know you're gonna have the right support
and it's not gonna be moving all over
the place yeah so you can wear this for
low impact medium impact and even high
impact activities basically it's bang
for your buck so let's take a look at
the back part of the sports bra so we
have typically criss-cross Razorback and
also tank top this what I have here is
Razorback so it creates like a Y shape
it is typically non adjustable so you
have to make sure that you get the right
fit right from the start and this again
goes over your head so some of us might
be struggling you know like you know
what I mean oh my god but but again I
love this type of sports bra because it
offers really good support even though
you are gonna feel like you know coming
out of a straitjacket most of the time
with something like this but it does the
job and criss-cross okay so criss-cross
like this one over here and over here
and over here crisscross usually can be
adjustable but it also can come without
any adjustable straps and this it can be
used for either the low medium or the
high-impact bra as you can see like this
one that I'm holding here is a low
impact bra and the crisscross you can
see that you can adjust it and fine-tune
it to however you feel it fits you best
yep and also the final category is the
tank top yup
so this tank top basically has a built
in sports bra and usually these types of
our outfit is suitable for low impact
activities those of you who enjoy doing
yoga Pilates or just brisk walking and
firstly it's great when you're traveling
less things to bring the reason why I'm
holding this here is because the tank
top also could mean where it's just like
your everyday bra wear is just two
straps like that it's a big hole there
is no crisscross at the back end the
final feature you want to take note of
for a sports bra is whether it's a
pullover or a clasp kind of bra so which
one do you prefer Joanna the pullover or
the clasp been the same for you I prefer
the club's actually so like what I'm
wearing right now it's because it's so
much easier to wear and so much easier
to take it off just like an actual bra
yeah correct
alright so explain a bit more about the
pullover first so with the pool over
types of bra it covers as a back part
more it is you know it is a great
support but honestly with those of you
with bigger boobs
it is hard to put it on and to get it
out yeah and then with the clasp it is
like I mentioned is like your everyday
kind of bra wear it keeps it around yeah
so this happens and there's a clasp over
there like this you know and no don't
take it out I'll put it on this is 70%
of where the support is coming from and
this is going to help tighten the band
for your sports bra this is really
important especially for those who are
more well endowed because you really
want to get that kind of support over
here so that's why if you actually look
at the charts a clasp kind of sports bra
is highly recommended for those with a
big
press yeah now that we know the
construction of the different types of
sports bra and if you already have
sports bra at home try it on and see if
it fits you right so here are four signs
that your sports bra doesn't fit you the
first is if you experienced breast or
back pain if your breasts or back hurts
it can mean that you are wearing a bra
with the wrong amount of support it
might be too loose hence it is not
holding your boobs in place or it might
be too tight and therefore yeah like
I've experienced it before when it when
it is too tight I just want to get out
of it
I I can't breathe - I kind of put it on
[Applause]
[Music]
like I was here and I say yeah I gotta
pull it out yeah you're coming out from
you're coming from your mom's womb does
what it feels like the second point to
find out you have the right bra when you
raise your hands up the band here should
not move see the band is where most of
the support is holding your boobies now
if the band goes up when your hands go
up that means it's probably too loose so
you need to find one that where the band
fits snugly onto your ribcage and it
doesn't move all place a good way to
actually gauge is taking two fingers and
you should be able to run it around it
should be just two fingers not more than
that it shouldn't definitely not be one
finger and the next point the shoulder
straps the shoulder straps should not be
digging into your shoulders like they
want to kill you it should be fit snugly
it's the same thing just like the band
two fingers so you should also be able
to run two fingers in the strap and you
know that is going to be comfortable for
you yeah so if you are constantly
pulling your sports bra down when you're
working out then it is definitely the
wrong fit and the final sign is that if
your breasts are spilling all over the
place I've experienced that before that
means you are buying a cup too small for
you you have to either go one size up or
maybe that design is just not for you
another fact one of the best ways to
find out if the the bra is your size
when you go to any
shop and they do the measurement for you
say for example I'm a 34b so find a
sports bra that is actually similar to
that they usually now in stores the from
even though it says s or XS Sofia they
would actually state 34b is actually an
S for example but still you got to try
it up okay whether it actually fits so
when you go into the store here is what
to do first of all you want to make sure
that your breasts sits comfortably in
the cup okay so it's not over spilling
it's not too loose and secondly raise
your hands up and down making sure that
the sports bra isn't going up or down
and the other thing is two fingers
around the band and on the straps to
make sure it fits nicely and snug and
the final part which is extremely
important
I don't care do it okay so I want you to
jump up and down alright run on the spot
I don't care if you want to run around
the store do it okay because you were to
really feel what the support is like
really good running those bright yeah
that's what I do I just run around I
mean like we're doing it now jump up and
down and sometimes I'll do I'll do
jumping jacks just to make sure there's
no like cheffing around the corners and
do all sorts of things because this is
an investment yes yeah I want to make
sure you have something good on you so
that you can focus on your training you
don't have to worry about that oh no
something's coming out here or something
is moving out there that is requesting
to it yeah loads when you are doing any
kind of mobile yeah activity it should
really enhance your performance for you
to perform better yes if you do have any
questions in regards to sports bras or
just training in general do leave us a
comment below okay let us know what do
you think about this video what do you
enjoy or if you have any other topics
which you would love for both of us to
share about let us know in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
my youtube channel head over to Lou
Norris YouTube channel subscribe to her
channel because you will find out a lot
more about I will be doing reviews I'm
also gonna be doing educational stuff on
how to train better and also meal prep
videos nutritional stuff with all that
is going to be on my
and also please hop on yeah and we will
see you next time bye-bye